hey guys it's Justine and welcome in my
kitchen it is hi Joey Graceffa you said
were making a cake and I said oh god
we're doing it again thanks so much to
YouTube originals for sponsoring this
video I can't wait for you guys to see
this season we've got these pre-made
things and we're gonna make an Egyptian
pyramid today I'm down
getting them to stick together and then
using this I know what's gonna happen so
I have a few little things here we've
got icing this might actually be mouldy
does icing get moldy how about you taste
it and if you die in like five minutes
oh oh is this like a challenge like an
escape tonight like when you guys buried
me in a coffin or who knows what
happened in this a new season Oh time
for the promo guys and you didn't know
it's keep the night All Stars season
four is coming out July 11 I don't know
when you're posting this but I don't
either
I'm here to save you guys okay and as
you killed us
Joey killed all these and my
necks prepared
we're at a museum of the dead once the
Sun rises if we're not out of here
we're all gonna turn to dust christine
is back for vengeance she's ready to
fight for her life a second time you
guys didn't know Joey buried me in a
coffin alive I mean it wasn't
necessarily you but it was still your
doing someone also say that I fought for
you to not be put in that coffin if you
well you weren't there because you were
putting coffee but I was crying I was
sad that you died and now we're going to
decide who's going in the coffin and be
buried alive oh my goodness
this is terrible oh my goodness
Justine
[Music]
guess what
it's an eye-for-an-eye to steam I know
perhaps an alliance maybe or maybe not
my girl bro but I thought it'd be really
fun sort of in that whole theme yeah
like a pyramid it's like a museum
vibe and you can see from the trailer
there's some mummies involved means
Germans I just think Oh hand and and I'm
not sure probably though I thought so I
maybe yeah what if we we cut these into
slick stretch yeah almost like bricks to
like make it what if we are off on our
cutting and measurements because I'm an
Egyptian pyramid builder by any means Oh
let's get started
okay I need to buy machete of course I
have a machete can you go get your
machete yes he never has I love people
ask about my machete I was kind of half
joking about that oh it's funny the last
we use this book was when you killed
someone
okay I don't think this is gonna work
yeah I'm sorry
unless I just don't know oh wow yeah
yeah machete it's made more for like
hacking up things I definitely
I think this might be it does kind of
smell a little poisoning alrighty so
this is looking good how are things over
there free for you well I thought it was
gonna be a lot quicker I'm still on my
first verse 15 oh thanks hmm all right
so now we're here I think we're done I
mean if we cut off half of this make
this a square then we just build this up
add some more we've got this extra stuff
over here and then we just kind of
cement it all together I'm gonna shape
it down into a pyramid okay that's a
square all right you've got a hacksaw oh
my god I've showed my chainsaw sucked up
saying oh my gosh I don't know raise the
crispys or so this yeah this is
industrial firm but this is a sharp
knife I wouldn't expect anything less
from Oh every Wednesday honestly I don't
know how the hell people made pyramids
that just shocks me we can't even think
about it laughs :
okay so now we're just building it up
higher which basically we just put these
together like this right and we can get
higher and higher I think that like in
theory this was a great idea I have not
given up yet this give me good because
even if this isn't entirely like a
straight pyramid we can just like keep
building on yeah let's do that okay
oh my gosh she's getting on the counter
with a knife don't try at all can you
not do anything that we're doing today
how's that look let's see okay oh my god
I'm not caught I'm not interested oh I'm
feeling confident about this I was
turning around yeah nice okay so we
started on that side by going down and
it went like this
so let's do that again this is wild
we have two very sharp pieces
thanks so much to YouTube originals for
sponsoring this video I can't wait for
you guys to see this season Wow
not bad look at them this way yes this
is this is beautiful
okay so I think next maybe we should
like mark it with a sharpie sharpie
I've got icing oh just a nice little why
I don't know if you'll be able to see it
on camera
we just need for our eyes it's for our
eyes but you guys if you happen to be
able to see it as well that's just added
bonus okay so then if we do that and
we'll chop that off that will give us
the pyramid this is absolutely just
really it's a very tall and skinny
pyramid but let's get to hack it I'm
gonna let you just like start first to
get like it will start Oh lovely oh that
was better than my original line I think
how are you a permanent pyramid pose how
are you at pyramid building and skip the
night
I forgot about that
I'm a little I'm so excited for you guys
to see the season all-star season come
on we have a question Gary moment though
where well there are multiple scary
moments but like I'm non like scripted
scary moment was when the power went out
yes oh my god Gracie because you shoot
this it is actually in the middle of the
night so you shoot all night long right
and it really is such an experience
yeah there's windows I thought that we
would have like a view Oh gorgeous you
know what they should have installed
windows what are they thinking gosh just
imagine building this for real I'm
hacking the pyramid is done it is all
well the shape all right Shane I feel
like we need to like judge her up we
need her to be like a little more juice
sandpaper I'm really impressed
not expecting masks I wasn't either and
I mean it looked so good I feel like we
don't need the icing but I mix this up
we're gonna use it would you like one of
these yeah
just get on in there girl Wow Wow see I
want to go for a nice smooth are you
saying my hands aren't smooth this is
how you get in all the nooks and
crannies oh nice you want a little
scrub-a-dub-dub here did we like it with
the processing or think I like it
actually I think it's pretty good we
kind of make it look like bricks using
this like this like a sea yes yes
[Music]
know what no no no no am I in trouble
girl this looks like african corn on the
cob if this was a real structure this
whole thing would be tumbling down it
does look like corn on the cob I was
just like you know thinking about corn
so I see what you're saying okay yeah
Wow looks a little less corn on the cob
II oh thank god
so now should we add in some accents
with the goal Oh me we fell in a good
idea okay here you do that okay I go
wash this hand oh yeah god I wish we
would have hoped this before I was on
escape tonight
Oh so where can everybody find the show
so escape the night season for all
escape tonight on my channel right now
you can see one through three for free
and then season four is probably out now
if it's past July 11th it's out now if
you guys don't know what the show is
basically it's like a giant escape room
for youtubers but we're interacting with
actors who know what's going on a lot of
people think that we're acting but we're
not you know we have no idea what's
happening none but you basically like
thrown into a massive escape room but
it's it's like real life and then we
have to vote against each other each
episode yeah I like that hard to people
go into a final death challenge and only
one makes out alive I'm so impressed
with that me too oh my gosh we did
something right Wow
we still need to add some torches yeah
right oh my gosh okay wait we should we
um okay I've got torches we could do
this and then like
jam a few of them in there like some
torches is it going in there yeah cool
oh my gosh it is so beautiful believe it
do we need anything else wow this is
like legends of the devil do you
remember that show absolutely like I
wanted to be on that show so bad well
guys thank you so much for watching this
is our incredible pyramid that we made
in honor of escape tonight season 4
it'll be on Joey's channel I'll put all
the links in the description below
anything else you'd like to tell them
about the show just there's a lot of
drama this season a lot of drama a lot
so if you want to see some of your
favorite youtubers die and make sure you
go check it out
well thanks so much this is so much fun
yeah thank you do you want to take it
home I can put it in like a little
ziploc bag for you I'll leave it here
for you
you
[Music]
[Applause]